we're hearing
at least initial
estimates are that emanuel macron has
come out with 28
of the vote
that would put him just ahead
and we have possibly with le pen at 23
of the vote why don't we cross over
right now to our correspondence in paris
we have
nope i think we can show the results
first good
all right so as we were saying emmanuel
macron with 28.1 percent to marine le
pen's 23.3 there of course other
candidates here but it's just the top
two that go on to the second round the
runoff of voting
this is initial preliminary results
according to the france 2 television
station again 28.1 percent with emmanuel
for emmanuel macron the incumbent
president and
23.3
for marine le pen his chief opponent the
far right opponent
there
now i think we can cross over to our
correspondence we have barbara vezel at
macon party headquarters and lisa lewis
in le pen's party headquarters let's
first turn to barbara
macron supporters how are they seeing
this initial result
absolutely what we hear here in the hall
of course is absolute jubilation joy and
she's a huge relief because the polls
during the last days have really been
relatively devastating for emmanuel
macron and there was this tremendous
fear among his party
party
and of course people who are voting for
him and rooting for him
that
marine le pen might sort of sneak past
him and do
do first place but it has not happened
and a five point difference between 28
for macron and 23 for her is good enough
to just give them this push and give
them hope that they can really do it
again in the second vote in two weeks
time that he now has enough momentum to
sort of pick up the campaigning and
really push people out to vote and and
sort of tell them that he is still for
another five years the right president
something that he has not done enough
during the last weeks and something that
sort of was reflected in the polls here
lisa lewis over to you at le pen's
headquarters are people disappointed
there
well they're really actually quite happy
as you might be able to see behind me
they've been singing the marseilles the
national anthem
we had hints earlier in the day that
that makha and le pen might be neck and
neck in this first round that seemed to
be untrue and yet people here seem very
happy marie le pen uh caught up in the
poles over the past past few weeks she
seemed very far behind a few months back
or only and now people feel that their
candidate here that she could actually
have a chance of winning the second
round of voting in the next in in two
weeks here in france
barbara back over to you how serious is
the challenge to macron going into the
second round of voting
the challenge has
now become somewhat smaller because
there was really tremendous fear among
his party and of course also the people
around him his his ministers and his
closest aides that marine le pen might
sort of come out first but with a
five-point lead he he
can sort of get momentum back because
his big strategic mistake in the last
maybe two or three months was that he
started his campaign very late he
thought he could sort of come out as
being the president and just be
re-elected for being the president and
that is something that the french didn't
take well to at all he had this problem
that people again were calling him
arrogant that they're calling him
elitist that he doesn't really step down
out into the markets and squares of the
small french towns of
provincial france something that marine
le pen has done
relentlessly throughout the last weeks
and months that he doesn't go out and
talk to people and listen to what they
have to say so he has sort of really
done what they always call his jupiter
number he has sort of tried to come from
above and not give people the feeling
that he really hears them and that he
really is close to them but in the end
it seems that the current political
situation even though during the
campaign
most people are saying the
buying power of their euro here in
france is the most important thing for
them the current political situation was
creating enough insecurity to sort of
drive sufficient people back into his
camp so that he now has a rather healthy
lead for the second round
lisa over to you
now marine le pen uh has done better
than many of the polls were showing how
did she manage to get so many of these
votes
well several things helped her during
this campaign first of all there was
another far-right candidate called eric
zumer who entered the campaign a few
months back and with what he said he
seemed even further to the right he had
outright racist slogans he was
announcing a crackdown on muslims a
crackdown on crime here in france and
that had marine le pere marie le pen
appear in a very a much softer light
especially as she tried to not talk
about all these controversial topics
that might scare off some vouchers even
though that happened though she was
still
not really leading in the past who was
far behind
up until a few weeks back then the war
in ukraine broke out and there was the
so-called flag effect and that meant
that people were rallying behind their
leader that is imani marco in times of
war he gained in the polls marine le pen
went down but over recent weeks that
effect really waned off because people
here in france felt that emmanuel macro
didn't enter the election campaign
in time and that he was very far away
from the people he only held a few
meetings really one big meeting only
here in paris about a week ago marie le
pen meanwhile she'd been campaigning
throughout france she'd been going to
cities to towns to markets telling their
people that she was the candidate that
would help them with their one number
one priority and that is spending power
as barbara just mentioned she said that
she would block the goods for essential
at the prices for essential goods that
she would do something about high fuel
prices and that she was as i said the
candidate close to the people and she
appeared a lot softer although obviously
her program remains the program of an
extroverse candidate that is highly
xenophobic
barbara back over to you where 2022
election is shaping up a little bit like
the 2017 election what does emmanuel
macron need to do to ensure that he wins
another term
he now really needs to go out and have a
social massive social media campaign
plus he really needs to go out and
campaign he needs to get his hands dirty
and he just needs to go out and talk to
people and give them a feeling that he
does listen to them
his record isn't that bad economically
he has really managed to lower
unemployment in france something that
hasn't happened in many years he has
sort of increased investment in
industries and he has generally i mean
inflation in france at the moment is
only 4.5 percent less than in germany
and other european countries he has had
a really good uh
relatively good uh corona pandemic he
managed that quite well so he has a lot
of positive points but he didn't sell
them to the people and he does need to
do that now and he really needs to go
out and sort of show himself not as this
god-like person sitting in the elysee
palace or at his guild desk but he
really needs to go out to people and and
talk like a human being he can do that
he has that talent but he just needs to
do this now urgently and then he can
carry a second round because if you look
at
the votes for the other parties there
was a huge chunk around 20 percent
voting for hard left
milan shaw a candidate who is sort of
come up year after year so some of those
voters he can lure back into his his
camp he can of course get some of the
green votes he can get this little bit
that is left of the traditional
conservative vote that's been a wipeout
for valerie big chris the party is just
annihilated
so he can he needs to collect those
votes actively and then he can do it he
can manage it because this five-point
difference is good enough to sort of
give him momentum but he really needs to
work now is something that he hasn't
done throughout the last months or two
and that was probably his biggest
strategic mistake so that's maybe some
campaign prescriptions for the macon
campaign lisa same thing for le pen she
has quite an uphill battle here what
would she have to do to actually beat
him
in the second round
well i think what she will do is try to
continue to appear as a soft candidate
that can speak to the french people in
the street mind you behind that soft
image image is obviously a very extreme
program one example is that if she got
to prior power she would hold a
referendum to basically enshrine what
she calls national priority in the
constitution into the constitution in
france and that would mean that french
people you know because of their not
nationality they were good access
priority access to housing to jobs to
things like healthcare so the very
principle of equality that was enshrined
in the french constitution friends
constitution after the 1789
revolution that would no longer exist
the very idea of you know of human
rights would no longer be valid in
france because obviously these human
rights are normally valid for everybody
no matter their nationality and by doing
that she would go against the principal
in the current principles in the current
french constitution but also on the
european level and that would possibly
or likely mean to a frexit uh an exit of
france out of the european union all
that though she will try to hide in
these two weeks she will talk about how
she will help the french to make ends
meet how she will block fuel prices how
she will reserve
national public tenders to french
companies and that she will use
protectionism to make people earn more
money here in france and to make it
easier for them to make ends meet
all right that's lisa lewis at the le
pen headquarters and barbara basil at
the macron headquarters thank you very
much for your work in shouting out over
that noise behind you
and dw correspondent marina strauss
is in central paris where people are
watching results of the elections marina
do people seem surprised by the result
what are they what are they seeing
william i'm uh i was at the left-wing
cafe a cafe though is very well known
for its uh for gathering left-wing
waters and you can just see it behind me
people are standing there outside the
cafe and still discussing the results
and i was in there when the results were
announced at eight o'clock and first
they said uh emmanuel macron then they
said marine le pen and then they said
sean luke melancho so the far left
candidate and when they said 20
percent for him
there was a bit of a
so people were really disappointed
because many of them lefting waters
hoped that he would make it into the
second round
i talked to a couple of them there was a
young woman and she said yeah she is
disappointed of course there were the
polls and they couldn't expect it but
everyone was still hoping for a a a
a
macro um jean-luc
melenchon battle in in the run-off vote
in two weeks but of course this now
likely won't be the case
so the left is out macron has done a
little bit better than what the latest
polls were looking at but le pen still
performed well tonight what does that
tell us about far-right politics in
france at the moment
it is very clear that le pen performed
better than five years ago five years
ago she had two percent of points less
and there was also another far-right
candidate in the race eric zamor he only
got an estimated seven percent about
seven percent of the votes so that is
not a lot but if you add it up it's
still a lot of people who in france who
vote for far right for extreme
candidates so you can clearly see that
there is an interest
in far-right candidates and as lisa
pointed out a bit earlier
marine le pen has tried to come across
as a more moderate candidate
in the last couple of years she tried to
polish her image she tried to talk to
people she tried to present herself as a
candidate for the working class for the
lower middle class someone who
understands the source of these people
and
she she seems
she seems to be someone who is now
is called votable but it still seems
likely that macro will make it in the
second round
all right marina strauss out there on
the streets of paris for us thanks very
much
and let's bring it back to the studio
now i'm joined by dwl political
correspondent with
more analysis on this election and what
it means for outside of france here in
germany first of all why does this
election matter to germany well because
when you think about europe the first
thing that comes to mind when you live
either in france or in germany is the
french german couple and if this doesn't
work out well there's a problem you know
at the head of the european union and
the uh you know the the tandem between
first emmanuel macron and angela merkel
has worked out uh quite uh well despite
some differences of opinions as to the
future of europe for example and now the
tandem with olaf schulz has also you
know
been quite coherent and of course this
election matters because you're not
going to have the same uh the same
understanding between the two countries
uh if mahindra penue to become france's
president right so let's get into that
what does the relationship look like if
it's a macon presidency versus a le pen
presidency well this would be the
difference between a euro fire
presidency which is that of emmanuel
macron and the euros captain presidency
which would be that of marine le pen
marine depend has
so far not really advertised her her
wishes for a fragrance so an exit of
france from the european union but if
you look at her program she doesn't have
a lot of words for the european union
and she's all about protectionism of
francis sovereignty and not really any
european ideas she is a euro skeptic she
has she had campaigned in the past on
that and she had tried to tone it down
as
as lisa was saying so she would appeal
to more voters but that would be the
difference between a eurofi presidency
which would be that of emmanuel macron
and eurosceptic presidency which would
be that of money in open now of course
how we view these candidates outside of
france is very different than how
they're viewed domestically can you get
into that more for us obviously voters
there see things very differently than
us here definitely emmanuel macron has
an international aura which he certainly
has not in france in france he's not
really popular he's seen as barbara visa
was saying it as quite an arrogant man
who doesn't want to
talk to uh you know people he doesn't
deem interesting enough for for him or
as a broad he's the man he's a euro
fighter he's the man of the disco uh
of the sorbonne the sovereign speech he
gave on the future of europe and the
future of france in the european union
in in 2017 he's also
the man who could still talk to donald
trump when donald trump was a president
he's the man who happened at the very
last moment wanted to talk to vladimir
putin before russia invaded
ukraine whereas marine le pen is quite
popular at home i mean we've seen
there's a quarter of french people who
are quite happy to see her as
you know a possible president she's not
so popular at least in western europe
it's a different story in eastern europe
she's very popular
with other euro skeptics within the
european union
but
for example you were asking how she's
seen outside there's a little anecdote
we haven't mentioned it yet she was
quite embarrassed uh a month ago a
little over a month ago when russia
invaded ukraine because in her
campaign program where she had put a
picture of herself with vladimir putin
to show that she was shining on the
international stage needless to say this
program didn't stay
long it wasn't distributed you know
there's a lot like the pretext was
there's a typo in the program so we're
not going to distribute it but she's
trying to descend distanciate herself
from that international image she wanted
to give definitely some bad timing uh
maybe for the french election this war
in ukraine you mentioned that macron has
played a central role uh when it comes
to negotiations when it comes to dealing
with vladimir putin how has the war
affected this campaign it has deeply uh
influenced this campaign simply because
there was
new to no campaign because of the war
emmanuel macron started his campaign
very very late uh he was clearly dis
dissociating uh his role as a french
president and representing france uh
abroad uh to that of uh his uh his was
as a candidate and baba avisa was
mentioning that maybe that has been
reproached to him that he assumed
you know his electorate would just
follow without him campaigning i think
there's a little bit more uh to that
he's a president in the middle of a
global conflict he did have
stuff to attend and you know there were
there was a priority of course the
political the the presidential campaign
is very important but when you have uh
the door uh
the war at the doors of europe obviously
he had some serious business to uh to
attend there
and not only ukraine there's just so
many issues that the german french
relationship have to deal with how do
those policies change if we have a macon
presidency or a le pen presidency well i
think we're going to see what happens
after the second round what would be
really interesting to see is the
position of the two candidates when it
comes to uh
to render france uh uh independent
energetically uh and also how they will
uh how how they will deal with that
together with germany we know that
germany is heavily criticized for not uh
wanting an immediate embargo on uh on a
russian fossil fuel on russian gas it
has started you know to to tone it down
a little by accepting a phased-out exit
from the russian
russian coal and and russian oil but
the core of the matter is russian gas
and of course again depending on who is
at the helm in france it will be very
interesting to see how that evolves at a
european level knowing that marine le
pen even if she has acknowledged that
the russian invasion was uh was not
right she has never
said anything bad about vladimir putin
which she for years called a friend
very interesting times especially if you
are a politician running for office
emmanuel chazz here in the studio with
me thanks very much for that analysis
thank you
and let's get that european perspective
over in brussels with our correspondent
jack parrack
jack how is brussels watching this
election
well clearly it was extremely closely
here in the quarters of the european
union where france plays a huge role in
all of the negotiations among the eu's
20 27 member states we'll say i think
there's been a slightly muted uh sense
of interest firstly because of how late
macron announced his candidacy his
re-candidacy and secondly because of the
war in ukraine which has obviously
consumed the political news cycle the
political messaging the political uh
site here in brussels but there is a
sense and i think this were this this uh
this result from the the first round
that shows actually a bigger spread
between emmanuel macron and marine le
pen than we saw back in the elections of
2017 uh there's there's no question that
the institutions of the european union
would prefer a re-elected president
under emmanuel macron they will not tell
you that there's never going to be an
official position but marine le pen is
also a known entity here in brussels she
sat as an mep for a long time and her
anti-eu stance is clearly well known the
question is what would that presidency
look like as you were as you were saying
what would a marine le pen president
actually look like if she did win in
that second round and as we're talking
to you jack we're looking at live
pictures from macon headquarters i
believe we're going to be waiting for
remarks from emmanuel macron
but while we're waiting for him let's
talk a little bit about
france and the eu rotating presidency it
is the eu president right now has that
chair that gives france a bigger role on
the european stage does that play into
uh french politics at all
i think it it certainly plays a big role
in the in the eu and we've seen you know
a lot of the meetings of the ministers
have now taken place uh in some of the
some french cities and obviously there's
been some big events in paris but i
think the reality is is that actually
what that's done is just consolidated
the french position as
quite a lead negotiator in the eu anyway
and as i say the political uh sort of
sphere the political move that has has
happened uh has been completely
dominated by by the war in ukraine i
think though when we look at emmanuel
macron's french presidency over the last
five years he has had some successes
you'll remember
you know as part of the uh president as
part of the the pandemic crisis response
emmanuel macron managed to essentially
to persuade german chancellor then
german chancellor angela merkel to
collect together to allow the european
commission the executive arm of the eu
to go out on into the international
markets and raise money for him
a man that has proposed and
i'm really pushed for eu financial
integration that's sort of a big success
here here in europe i don't know how
well he's actually been able to sell
that to the french voters or how much
they they actually care about that
william
you mentioned uh some of those uh you
know
the pandemic response for example
macronus has really thrown down the
gauntlet when it comes to what the eu
and even nato can do
how have these major western
institutions change throughout makan's
first term what might they look like if
he gets a second
well i think that that idea of the the
financial getting the european
commission to raise money on the
financial markets that was a massive
massive step we don't have too much of a
clear policy from from his
electioneering i mean i think he wanted
to take a hard line on foreign policy as
we've seen he's tried to play that
friend to vladimir putin ahead of ahead
of the invasion of ukraine he was on the
phone with him many many times and now
he's had to sort of reposition himself
after
after what became a sort of awkward
position for him in the european union
but one thing i one thing i will say i
think he's considered here in brussels
as as
a known entity of one of the big eu
member states i mean so much has
happened since that election in 2017 and
and also what we've seen is the end of a
huge era of german chance then german
chancellor angela merkel leaving and
olaf schultz while he's
already sort of working his way through
the european council and the
institutions here he's still not quite
the the sort of solid fixed entity that
we saw under german chancellor under
angela merkel so the question is you
know how does a a second presidency for
emmanuel macron how would that fit he
would obviously have a lot more power a
lot more prowess as as a politician and
and if in the second round he does
potentially get beaten by marine le pen
what would that mean i mean that would
be a huge huge shift in thinking in one
of the eu's biggest eu member states and
that would change quite a lot of things
there's a lot of stake here in this
french election for the european union
well actually what i think is
interesting is what's happened as far as
i've seen from from the perspective in
brussels is that the campaigning has
been far more domestic actually
as we've been reporting incumbent
emmanuel macron has emerged as the
winner of the first round of the french
presidential election initial
projections put macron at 28 percent of
the vote his main challenger the far
rights marine le pen trails with 23
now both contenders will go forward into
the second round in two weeks time ten
other candidates from different parties
of the political spectrum have been
eliminated
and we can get more on all of that with
our dw correspondent barbara basil who's
standing by at macron's party
headquarters so barbara macron facing
far-right le pen in the runoff election
what's he going to do to rally the
support of the supporters of all the
other candidates who didn't make it
through
we just heard a discussion of party
representatives of all the parties
that had been running and
during these elections in the background
here and
somebody from the left just said
he needs to step down from his pedestal
and really campaign and that is
something that probably he has by now
understood because
his advisors must have told him this is
the very last moment that he really has
to go out and get close to the french
people we have also during the last
minutes heard that he has got two
endorsements he's got the endorsement
from valerie pigress who who failed
miserably was under five percent her
task had been to revive the
conservatives the traditional french
conservative party and she couldn't
manage it at all but then she just came
out and said i have wanted more but i
failed and now please everybody put
their vote to macron because we have to
block the far right and we heard the
same from also around five percent from
the greens
because they also said
he was the only candidate where climate
and and green issues have a chance at
all and we have to block the far right
so things are sort of moving his way and
also if you look at the whole
panorama of parties here as something
that is very interesting is that the
extreme far right firebrand these
several times as uh
tried as a hate preacher eric zimmer
came out with about six to seven percent
only that is about half what he had at a
point in his election campaign it shows
that the extreme right in france seems
not quite as strong as predictions
during the campaign had been
so where could
marine le pen get those additional votes
from that she needs they probably don't
exist and things seem to be turning more
in the direction of emmanuel macron
all right barbara vezel thanks for
standing by we'll be back with you when
mcconnell speaks a little later but
let's turn over to the le pen
headquarters where our lisa lewis is
standing by
lisa marina penn she was just addressing
that crowd live what was her main
message
well she's basically saying that she
wants to talk to every french person in
this country that people should forget
about their party affiliation just
remember that she is the candidate of
the people now that's obviously
underlining her main strategy in this
campaign she has been trying to tell
people that she's the candidate that
will give them more money in their
pocket that will block a prices for
basic goods here in france and help her
make and help them make ends meet and
that is as you know the top priority of
the french voters in this election
campaign and she said you know we need
to look at this
run-off vote in two weeks time and we
need to gather our strength to win that
run-off vote
and so she might not have done as well
as she was hoping but she did better
than many people thought how did she
manage to get the votes that she did
well first of all you know she really
did the leg work she went from town to
town from market to market for from city
to city in france for months she talked
to people and was right quite close to
them really and she dropped all the
controversial messages you know the
tough anti-immigration stunts that
really she obviously talked about that
that was that was not her main message
meanwhile there was another factor uh
eric zamora another far-right candidate
that seemed even further to the right
than marine le pen he was you know
campaigning with outright xenophobic
slogans against immigrants against
muslims a crackdown on crime and that
had marina penn appeared in a much
softer life now obviously the programs
that the candidates are actually quite
similar but people seem to have
forgotten about that another factor is
that you know the war in ukraine
although that first of all called a flag
effect that is people rallied around the
leader here in france
he went up several points in the polls
and marine le pen went down also because
she's known to be quite close to have
been quite close to putin in the past
and to even have received financing from
russian banks for a campaign this time
around last time around and she actually
went down in the polls first of all but
then that had an adverse adverse effect
because imam makhan did not enter the
campaign for a long time really at the
last minute only he declared his
candidacy candidacy he only held a few
meetings whereas marilla penn continued
to do the legwork and that's how she
gained in the polls again because people
felt that she was talking to them
directly whereas
seemed quite disconnected from you know
day-to-day reality in france
all right lisa lewis there competing
with a lot of chanting behind her we'll
let you leave it there thanks very much
for the latest from le pen's
headquarters
and back in the studio now with me is uw
political correspondent emmanuel chaz
with the bigger picture i feel a little
bit like we're having deja vu to borrow
a french expression uh 2017 we saw
pretty much the same thing how does this
election in 2022 stack up to what we saw
in 2017. well i think at each election
in france we see the danger of having
the far right come into power a bit
closer and you see the margins between
the candidate narrowing at each election
and this is a worry that uh we've seen
here in germany with at least the last
two elections with the a ifd party the
afd party the uh right-wing party here
uh in germany and uh it's uh uh it's
interesting to see how this was
perceived back then where the rest of
europe and especially in france
everybody was panicking was uh seeing
that the far right was entering the
german parliament once again knowing
that that the last time was actually
before world war
ii and uh actually when we look at
what's happening in france we've seen a
steady
rise of the far right and marine le pen
has done the score she has done tonight
which is already almost a quarter of the
electors who would see would like to see
her as a candidate but they were there
there were even two uh far-right
candidates uh in france and the farad is
really more important representatively
in france than it is uh in germany so
that would be something that uh i
i would find quite interesting to see
this surge of the far right why is that
because there's a surge of populism all
across uh all around
the globe at the moment but in france
it's particularly strong and emmanuel
macron has also lost a lot of his uh of
his electors of 2017
to the far right that's us on another
point that is not worthy at this
election french politics is known for
being feisty it's hard for presidents to
stay in power and just continue their
support what would a makon's second term
mean for him this would be somewhat
historic i think well i think he's he's
he has overcome a pandemic he has
handled the pandemic those were already
difficult times now he's probably going
to focus on external policies with the
war in ukraine so a lot of foreign
policy to do for emmanuel macron should
he
be elected for a second term manual
shares thanks very much
and to give you a latest on where we're
at with the first round of voting in
france the incumbent emmanuel macron has
emerged as the winner in that first
round initial projections
putting macron at you can see it right
there 28 of the vote with his main
challenger the far-right marine le pen
trailing at 23
now that means both contenders will go
forward into the second round of voting
the runoff in two weeks time the other
candidates the 10 other candidates from
various other political parties have
been eliminated
you